hello john perry here welcome to what i
have now decided to call the evolution
podcast it used to be called sunday
morning science things are changing this
is the evolution podcast
my guest today is dr john coffin he is a
virologist at tufts university in boston
he has spent his career studying
endogenous retroviruses and
active retroviruses like hiv and so on
in this conversation we cover everything
you've probably ever wondered about
endogenous retroviruses aka
ervs aka herbs he calls them herbs i've
been calling them ervs i've been saying
the acronym wrong this entire time but i
didn't even notice that until i was
editing this podcast afterwards we
actually start out by discussing hiv and
dr coffin's
essential role in the discovery of
reverse transcriptase the protein that
hiv uses to make a dna copy of its rna
genome before inserting that genome into
its host cell's genome
the discovery of reverse transcriptase
was a huge deal because it proved first
off that the so-called central dogma of
genetics as it's often taught wasn't
really correct
not exactly correct watson and crick had
been saying that dna always acts as a
template for rna and then rna always
acts as a template for protein but we
found out that actually rna can act as a
template for dna as well so it threw a
bit of a wrench in our understanding of
genetics and second it showed us a very
important way in which genes can jump
from one species to another through
viral infection and other types of
routes that use reverse transcriptase
that kind of threw a wrench in how we
thought evolution always worked right
we had assumed that inheritance always
happened from mother to child but not
always without the discovery of reverse
transcriptase many things we find in the
dna sequences of various organisms would
not make sense it was truly a
groundbreaking discovery and you get to
hear about dr coffin's role in that and
then we also talk a little bit about
covid dr kaufman has not worked directly
on covid but of course in the field of
virology people know each other and he
even uh mentions his interactions with
one of the troublemakers you may have
come across during the pandemic so far
one of the troublemaker virus
researchers
i really enjoyed this conversation i've
been working with dr coffin for
i guess we first got in contact over a
year ago when i was doing the animation
about endogenous retroviruses ervs herbs
the conversation gets a bit more
technical at times than conversations
usually get on this channel but if
you've seen the animation i think you'll
be able to follow everything just fine
without further ado here is my
discussion with the great john coffin
biologist and professor of molecular
biology
thanks for coming on john well thank you
very much for the invitation i'm looking
forward to this for those who don't know
dr coffin he's one of the main people
who helped advise me on the animation on
endogenous retroviruses if you haven't
seen that yet that's
worth taking a look at yeah it was
wonderful having your help on that and
then also the book that you had written
that was a huge help for me for just
referencing back and forth and and
wrapping my head around this before i
kind of dig into the questions i i just
learned i was reading your wikipedia
page and i just learned that you worked
under howard temen he's the one who he's
credited for discovering reverse
transcriptase were you with him before
he had discovered that or yes i was
there at the time the discovery was
actually made by by satoshi mizutani who
was a postdoctoral fellow in in the lab
at the time it was based on an idea that
howard had had based on genetics based
on the genetics of the viruses he was
studying this is long before hiv was
discovered this is another retrovirus
called called raw sarcoma virus that
causes cancer in chickens
but he he
he came to the conclusion that the
virus which has a genome of rna
must change that rna into dna and insert
it into the dna of the cell
in order to in order to make more copies
of itself in order to replicate
uh but it was many years before he came
up with the insight that he that he
needed to actually prove that idea
given given especially that relative to
today the method methodology was very
very primitive he finally had the idea
satoshi did the experiment the
experiment was to look in the virus
itself the virus particles themselves
for the enzyme that
that get called reverse transcriptase
that changes that rna to dna in order to
do that
uh you have to break open the virus a
little bit so you can get because the
viruses in it has a shell on it that
that prevents
things from getting in and out
particularly the cut the chemicals you
want to give it to be able to test for
the presence of the enzyme you have to
treat it with a gentle detergent you
know like your dishwashing detergent but
something much much more gentle than
that that'll break open the
poke holes in the virus but won't just
won't damage the enzyme
yeah and for that he needed the special
the special detergent well i i was the
one that had the bottle of special
detergent to load him
nice
so so it's your discovery basically well
yeah
without without without my without my
getting that which i had for a
completely different purpose but
i just happen to have
that's funny
it's really interesting to try and think
about
like for me i i just learned about these
things in textbooks of course there's a
reverse transcriptase because it has to
get its
you know rna into dna and then that
needs to go into the genome but it's
it's just amazing to think
i mean
these things are too small to see not
not not living
electron microscopy is very powerful for
looking at viruses but you have
you have to
to to fix the virus and
and um or whatever the cells that it's
in and so on
you can't you can't follow it moving
around or anything like that an electron
microscope everything has to be kind of
stuck down you can basically through
microscopy find all the parts of the
virus
but you don't get a picture as to how
they all work together you have to work
that out logically like
we know what the virus does how is it
doing it and
i mean it just seems like such a mess of
a puzzle to try and solve well if you go
back through the literature i mean you
just it's a series of very very
mostly
of very very small steps and then again
there's a all of a sudden everything
sort of crystallizes in one person's
mind sometimes and the most in the most
dramatic of these which is which this is
one of
and there's a sudden everything comes
together and then you realize that
sitting in front of you is the one
killer experiment that you can do to
show that all of this is true i mean the
reason that i i wanted to bring that up
is because reverse transcriptase of
course is essential for understanding
how retrovirus endogenous retroviruses
work that and integrase was integrase
discovered afterward or the integration
step was certainly part of the model
howard had had put together in this met
this this height this theoretical
construct that he developed which tried
to be completely correct but uh the
enzyme itself and how that works and so
on actually remained quite a mystery for
quite a number of years beyond that we
knew that the step had to happen but it
was a long time before
other workers were able to solve the
puzzle just how that happened are both
of those enzymes packaged in the virus
or both of them are in the virus yes
yeah
and then and then they're mass-produced
inside the cell as well but
the uh the actual what the individual
molecules that actually do the reverse
transcription
and the integration are actually
pre-packaged in that
particle they come in in the case of
retroviruses they come in as part of the
virus and there's just one of each
no they're one they're multiple copies
they're about
uh
a few hundred copies of each okay and
okay that that makes sense having just
you only need one if you think about it
but maybe two yeah yeah if you only had
one you you risk
having it it's a function yeah it's so
neat that evolution can solve these
problems even discovering what the best
number of enzymes to package inside of a
virus particle might be you can
rearrange so you make mutations in the
virus that will cause it to package far
more of those and now the virus has
stuff's so full it doesn't can't do
anything so yeah yeah that's interesting
so there is an optimum very fine balance
there yeah people were playing around
with retroviruses so just just for
people who haven't watched the
the videos that you should watch before
watching this
you know retroviruses very specific type
of virus they have an rna genome and
they actually convert that into dna and
insert that into the cell's genome
so there are a lot of rna viruses i mean
cova sars cov2 the thing that causes
cova-19 that is a
an rna virus but it's not a retrovirus
it doesn't turn its genome back into dna
and insert it into the cell's genome it
just
has an rna genome so
people were playing around with
retroviruses for a long time even before
we discovered hiv so
what retroviruses mess with humans aside
from hiv
well the first one
first one to be discovered was a virus
called htld
htlp which causes the kind kind of
leukemia or lymphoma
kind of cancer blood cancer infects a
lot of people although not not much in
the us it's pretty rare in the u.s but
in some parts of the world in effect a
lot of people are infected
where is it most common in the far east
in china japan big pockets of it on in
australia actually particularly among
the aboriginal populations so we'd known
about that for a long time and then
uh we were
mainly focused on these in chickens is
that right chickens and mice
yeah the the viruses and chickens were
actually discovered um
now
at the very beginning of the 20th
century so over years ago had been
studied as models for you know for a
long time ever since one of the main
ones that had been used was a virus
called browse sarcoma virus which causes
a kind of a sarcoma which is a cancer of
solid tissue which if you inject the
virus into a chicken the cancer will
grow as a big lump right right
right and it'll eventually kill chicken
and that was discovered by a fellow
named peyton rouse
in about 1911 he won the nobel prize for
that in 1965 by the way he lived
55 years after after that after
publishing that discovery
long enough to get the nobel prize
that's that's really neat so
there are a lot of viruses that cause
cancers do we think that's an actual
adaptation for the virus does it help
the virus in some way no i i don't think
so i think for the most part it's
actually
it's not it's it's not good for the
virus diseases caused by viruses are
important for the virus only if they
help the virus in some way
for example a virus that causes you to
sneeze a lot
yeah that's good for the virus because
it helps spread the virus to other
people a virus that causes diarrhea is
the same same kind of thing
viruses that cause cancer don't really
help that vein don't really have that
property very much
yeah so the cancer is often a sort of a
side effect of some other process that
the virus does is good for it
okay an accidental byproduct very
unfortunate accidental bipolar very
unfortunate one for us and for the virus
actually because virus kills its host
too fast without having the opportunity
to spread then that will die it'll die
out too once a virus has been with us
with a specific host long enough it's
going to have balanced that um you know
the pros and cons of killing your host
too soon right
in a lot of cases what happens is that
what you
that's true in the natural host it takes
a while for that relationship to evolve
a long time you know millennia millions
of years probably for that relationship
to evolve to that kind of stable state
and before that time uh the virus might
be quite
more pathogenic than would actually be
good for it it takes a while for the and
both the host and the virus adapt to one
another you spend a lot of time studying
hiv it comes from chimpanzees it's siv
in chimpanzees that's what it's called
yeah it's basically it's virtually the
same virus but that's what it's called
and with the chimp host do they have a
symbiotic relationship or no i think
actually no
and that's because it hasn't been in
chimpanzees very long either oh okay
it's a fascinating story it turns out
that the virus actually comes from two
other viruses and two other
uh african primates with lower monkeys
and those two viruses got together in
the chimpanzees somehow
chimpanzees actually monkeys the
combination of they recombined that is
to say the combination of them got it
was something that was more potent as an
effect it's an infectious agent for
chimpanzees but as far as we know it's
only been in chimpanzees for a few
thousand years it's a very short
timeliness
so it does still cause disease diseases
in them right and the same thing is
certain gorillas
and that family of viruses doesn't
usually cause
um
endogenous retroviruses does it no yeah
no there are there are very few rare
examples in some far-flung species that
are of that are distant cousins i would
say
of hiv
that have become endogenous it had
become endogenous but they're they're
just scattered and occasional species
here and there they're not widespread at
all there's some types of viruses where
every mammal has
has some copies of it pretty much when
and where were ervs first discovered
like how
how long is this is our understanding of
these things and then then was it hard
to convince the scientific community
that they existed it goes back to around
the late 60s
right around 1970 i was still a graduate
student at the time and um it was they
weren't discovered in our lab they
didn't have to teminate at the time
there were a couple other labs
and and actually the first discoveries
were um
were genetic genetic
it was discovered that
rouse sarcoma virus
sometimes comes in in a way that's kind
of defective
and and doesn't replicate well
uh unless you have two viruses growing
together so you have one virus called
the helper virus and then another virus
the routes are common virus and you need
both of those
because the roster como virus is
actually missing some of the genes that
it needs
those are provided by another virus so
if you have this mixture of two viruses
in the same cell that will grow
well it was discovered um that in some
cells
you didn't need that helper virus
oh okay
and that was because there was already
an endogenous virus an herb if you like
in those in chickens in some chickens
not all chickens but in some chickens um
that
was providing exactly the things that
this virus needed to grow
wow that was really the first discovery
and it was based pure genetics and
biology
um
at about the same time that was in
chickens
about the same time in mice it was
discovered
that um
some mouse cells if you took them out of
the mouse and put them in culture and
grew them but sometimes start to make
virus all of their own
yeah and you could you could detect this
virus in very various ways
could you could look at the electron
microscope for example and see the virus
coming out
yeah
or you could look for you could there
were assays for
viral proteins of various assays for
viral proteins you could do and see
those virus coming out and after a lot
of careful work you know they excluded
the possibility
the first reaction is why you
contaminated your cultures with some
virus that the next guy was working with
but after a lot of very careful work
they excluded that and they could
actually do genetics and show it some
mice had some mice carry this and some
carry these in active
herbs and some didn't this is long
before we had any of the tools that we
attribute to modern molecular biology
today where you would just be able to
pull that out and determine the sequence
of it very quickly so that was in cell
cultures that was an actual mice
and in mice and then then in mice you
could see the same thing happening
so so mice actually still express entire
viruses but they can yes and might and
mice are somewhat unusual that way
actually a new virus will come into a
species
and will spread through it like hiv is
today and
it it will spread through it
and if it's the right kind of virus
um it can infect the germline cells and
precursors to sperm into eggs that's how
an endogenous retrovirus a nerve is
is generated is by infection of
of of the
the germline if you like the germline
there's
a series of cells and
males or females that give rise to
the next generation
and if those get infected with the
retrovirus then the offspring will have
the that virus dna
in every single one of their cells
and then that can that'll get past can
get past the next generation next
generation next generation and so on
mice have been used by scientists of
course for hundreds of years
and by sort of most fancy years people
just like to grow them as pets and and
and try to find ones with special
characteristics and fancy looking or
fancy behaviors and yeah read those
and that actually was a precursor to the
to the scientific work of the most and
some were bred for high high frequency
of cancer without knowing what was
causing this
and when they did that it turned out
they bred for certain combinations of
these earths that these might said
there's another collection that that
have a high incidence of mammary cancer
it's called mouse memory tumor virus
yeah that virus can also be passed
actually can be passed in two ways it
can be passed
uh
in milk
uh to the offspring but can also be
passed in the genes for the offspring so
that's definitely still expressing yeah
this expression is very tightly
controlled actually to be expressed only
in the memory plan
not really trains of mice were bred for
instance this kind of cancer and
basically what happened was you had
selected for me perhaps relatively rare
mice to begin with the ones that had the
right combination of herbs that kind of
genetics and phenomenology that was was
the original groundwork to discover
endogenous viruses
nice we didn't we didn't really
appreciate the extent of it so
um until about around 2000 when we had
started when the genome sequences were
appearing
okay that's really interesting you knew
you had them on mice and it was was it
fairly easy for researchers to convince
themselves and the rest of the community
that that these it wasn't so hard
um for one thing the community was
fairly small at the time and so yeah
yeah everybody knew everybody pretty
well
and um
and and
these were very good scientists who were
doing this and so it wasn't it actually
wasn't very hard
but
this work was not did not i don't think
it came to the attention of of what you
would call real cancer researchers
people who worked on human cancer that's
interesting was the cancer community not
even very queued into the fact that
viruses can cause cancer it took a while
okay
it took a while the virologists are just
kind of sitting on this i mean
it didn't make noise
in the mainstream i mean never got in
the newspapers or anything that
viruses exist inside of us already i i
don't remember
anything really hitting the news the way
things do these days
that's interesting see you make this a
crazy discovery it's well known within
virology and nobody else nobody else
knows about it
my
my dog is telling me that she wants to
go outside hold on one second
around what time would you say that
everybody was
interested in ervs well i think the
release of the human genome sequence
um really brought that in pretty
dramatically when it was when you could
see in the sequence that a very large
fraction of our dna
it consists of remnants of retroviruses
yeah estimate was you know the initial
estimate was about eight percent right
that that
number is still a little rough but that
that's what's usually quoted at what
point did you decide that this is
something so interesting i need to spend
my time looking well i i had i had um
decided that i wanted to work on nerves
back in when i was finishing
just starting my independent career i
finished my postdoc
my first the first grant that i wrote to
apply for funding for them when i when i
moved from my postdoctoral position
which was in switzerland
not to dust
on switzerland i we had i worked on uh
some very fundamental aspects of virus
replication and then was taken by the
observations with this night about 1975.
yeah um and so 1975 was when you moved
to tufts right yeah okay and um
and so we started
had some ideas based that kind of
build on the sort of the basic
observations and things we wanted to
look at one thing these viruses of
chickens for example the endogenous
viruses don't cause disease particularly
unlike like the very closely related
exogenous viruses that you can get and
so
we're interested in working on this
difference and see if we could figure
out what it was and what that would tell
us about the disease process what
percent of your time would you say that
you've spent on erv specifically i mean
a lot of your work was on hiv but it's
probably about half
oh nice
so you know it comes and goes a lot i
mean sometimes
almost for some over some periods of
time
you know it's almost everything we're
doing in the lab in other periods of
time and other things going on too yeah
and it is erv research i mean is it like
a big thing at their conferences just
about erv there are there are
conferences in which it's a major part
and there are occasional conferences
just on that although i think we haven't
how many researchers would you say focus
most of their time on there's probably
thousands in laboratories and you know
research research groups a few hundred i
would guess
yeah there are some that that are are um
really focused for example in australia
these viruses are kind of a big deal
because there's a lot of uh i mean
an epizootic if you like of
retroviral infection in koalas it's
really had a devastating effect
and and and those are becoming
endogenous at the same time and so in a
sense you can follow this process and
that's from those animals in real time
so that's a big it's a
really cool nation in australia
and a couple of their labs outside
outside and are associated with some zoo
animals are we still finding brand new
ervs in the human genome or have we
pretty much mapped them all out a few
were still popping up
but i think the human genome was pretty
well
understood now
yeah
and we're finally sort of
getting at the real dark matter in the
center meters and things so
that's because that's coming to light
and some things hide in there
i i suspect there may still be a few
sort of rare ones too they're different
groups and they they vary considerably
in the number that are in the genome
some some just a couple
some it's many thousands
yeah and to find them we're just looking
for
wait what we look at sequences of
viruses that we find and then compare
that to the human genome is that yeah
yeah but basically
uh actually it's in a sense it's sort of
the other way around usually it's a
matter of scanning scanning the human
genome looking for
sequences that have
signals that make it look like a virus
okay or or that are
visibly related to
to a known virus there could be types of
viruses that we that are just very
different right
it wouldn't be a huge shock to find ones
that were in the human genome that have
been overlooked the other thing that
happens to these is that some of the
ones in our genome have been there for a
very very long time 20 30 million years
and all
handed down to us from our ancestors 20
30 million years ago which were very
very you know small little
proto-primates of various kinds of with
time they get eroded
they're very slow just you know normal
normal mutational processes which occur
very slowly it's like it takes a long
time but yeah 100 million years is also
a long time so right right those would i
guess hide the signal that we're looking
at a virus because you've got a bunch of
point mutations or other larger
mutations well the other thing that
happens here lots of lots of different
kinds of mobile elements
yeah and so those have also landed
inside these
and sort of split them up and you gotta
you gotta work fairly hard sometimes
just to sort all that out and to kind of
reconstruct the code that was originally
there you can have a chunk that's
deleted from some sort of deletion event
you could have a big insertion right in
the middle of it
so the whole thing
i guess you're looking for the
yeah like the long terminal repeats you
can find those
yeah that's one of the that's one of the
things you look for if you're looking
for is the long-term repeats
as as time goes on as as the
eons pass by those begin they're
identical
exactly identical the time they're put
there yeah yeah they start to
they start to accumulate changes just
random changes very very slowly but they
drift apart
and we actually i think we're the first
to point out that you can use this rift
actually to date them
yeah because the accumulation of these
mutations it creates some kind of what's
called a molecular clock it's a fairly
constant rate i mean average average
rate is fairly constant
and um
you can use that to tell how old these
things are when when it was put in how
do we calibrate those clocks are we
calibrating them against
fossil
records we're largely calibrated against
other
um information
uh that allows us to estimate the time
of divergence of species
okay so we know from other from from
fossil records you know from layers
strips stratigraphy and things like that
all of those kinds of tools
independent tools we know approximately
when humans and chimpanzees split off
split apart
so if there's a pro virus that's present
in a nerve that's present in humans and
chimpanzees
then that had that existed as a virus
more than say six million years ago
right
if it's also in gorillas you push that
back to about 10 million years and so on
yeah and if it's also and say rhesus
monkeys and you know other other
non-non-ape monkeys you go back
30 million years or so something like
that we can tell by just doing
comparative
ervs on different species
you know roughly how old things are and
then you can also look at the virus
itself look at the the upstream in the
downstream
long terminal repeats
and count the differences between those
two and you've got you've got basically
two
two time estimates to uh to play off of
each other for for better accuracy some
years ago we published it very
interestingly sometimes those don't line
up and
what that tells you is that
something else interesting has happened
in the meantime and what are the things
that can cause that not i there's um
there's gene
gene conversion i think is probably the
word you're looking for yeah gene
conversion so that's where we get
recombination where where one gene is
kind of oh over copied over another one
yeah a related one related but somewhat
different one and which it gets
basically switched out and that is and
you can use you can actually use this
these anomalies between the
species distribution and the ltr
aging to
detect those kinds of things
yeah
and that's that's a mechanism for
gene repair if there was damage to a
gene that's a mechanism for clean repair
exactly if there's damage then there's a
machinery that cell has to do that
yeah and it's also the other thing is
that kind of recombination
is part of the natural process of
meiosis
yeah of generating sperm and egg cells
where you strip down to half a genome
anyways that's probably a little
complicated to get it right here but but
basically that that's that's probably
where a lot of this occurs a lot of the
erv studies on how they actually insert
themselves into the genome that's been
done on mice some of it's on chickens do
you feel like that's good enough for
letting us understand how they work in
humans the broad brush level and the
general principle level yes you get down
to details the details can be quite
different because because the virus
you're talking about different viruses
they have different properties they tend
to be expressed
their mechanism of making rnas a little
bit different in this in that they they
they like to replicate in certain
tissues better than others i mean as an
example these are often viruses that are
transmitted as a virus from mother to
offspring
through milk is an example i i mentioned
already but other others can be
transmitted by infecting across the
placenta for example the viruses evolve
special characteristics that allow it to
do that in the case of infecting across
a placenta for example
that means that the virus has to be able
to infect the outside layer of the
placenta which is called the tropoplasty
and then get moved through that be made
by that cell and pushed out the other
side by after after it replicates inside
the cell
well
uh so those viruses evolve
use
to be able to get through a cell the
virus has to use a specific protein on
the surface it's usually a protein
called a receptor
and so these
receptors are very can be very different
in different cell types they're not in
the cell for the sake of the virus to
help the virus along the way
around the cell for other other very
important cell reasons
and um
and so these some of these viruses
learned how to use this specific
receptor that's specific for these
that's found on these cells
well that fire so some of those viruses
became endogenous in our very very
distant ancestors they turned the nerves
they infected the germline
and
they expressed this protein that
recognizes the receptor
and this protein is is a protein of the
viruses not only recognizes the receptor
but it's a little machine that causes
the
the membrane of the virus the membrane
of the cell to fuse together
right so it's like pushing two soap
bubbles together the the virus then
opens out and the virus is all of a
sudden inside the cell this virus has
become endogenous it's become a nerve
and
it actually are very distant ancestors
and also is expressed on these cells
during very early embryogenesis
what it does is when it's expressed on
these cells it's on the surface it's
just this protein not the whole virus
right causes these cells to the cells to
fuse together the same way the virus and
the cell will fuse together
and then what that does is cause these
cells which are on the surface of the
placenta
to be fused into a solid layer of cells
that has no breaks in between it right
and that's actually very very important
for embryogenesis for development of a
developing embryo
because that blocks anything that is not
supposed to get into the developing
embryo or the fetus and the baby if you
like
uh from passing through
through the cracks in between the cells
there are no cracks in between the sides
anything that's going to get into
from the mother's blood into the fetal
blood
has to be actively taken up and
passed through these cells
and so that that and every single
mammal that's been studied and actually
even even some fish actually okay
that have a a a co-opted virus
this is called co-option if you write
i have a co-opted virus that expresses
this protein one of these proteins it's
a different virus it's happened
different times in each of the mammalian
lineages so there's one in there's one
in primates which is of course us and
all the monkeys and things uh there's
one in rodents
yeah there's a different one in
ungulates sheep and horses and so on
there's a different one in
uh
in carnivores but there are everybody
or at least one sometimes a couple so
it's really a remarkable aspect of
endogenous viruses
sometimes very rarely
but sometimes they can actually make
important contributions
yeah well let me let me try and tease
out the the mechanics here a little bit
more so you have it's the it's the
developing baby that's expressing the
virus right so it's it's the baby side
not the mother side of the
placenta
it's just it's just in those cells it's
yeah
so so the very first few divisions of
the of the growing fetus
those produce these cells that are still
expressing that are expressing this
virus protein that virus protein causes
all those cells to fuse with each other
so you get this
fusion basically one giant single cell
and then the fetus continues to develop
and it somehow suppresses that virus
protein well it's actually a little
different from that it's it's kind of
the other way around the placenta starts
to develop and then in very early
placentas where this expression appears
and and really just in the cells that
are going to become this trophoblast
layer
okay so it's quite a little better
coordinated than what you say it's a
little more a little more specific
process
yeah
and do we have more than one virus
that's co-op to do this there are a
couple whether in humans i don't know
whether they're both important or not i
don't know okay one one of them we know
a lot we know more about one than the
other because it's it's it's it's
more perfect this was this this goes
back
early to the to the to the dawn of
of primates
you're talking you know something
pushing 100 million years
yeah
this was a virus way back then but you
can take that gene it's called a
sensitive in this context but you can
take that out put it into a virus the
virus works
despite the fact that this hasn't been
in a virus for 100 million years or
whatever can we find around that gene
other genes from a virus that are just
you can you can but they've been really
scrambled
okay
see you can see the remnants of them but
they've they've been blasted by the
sands of time but this one but this one
gene has been perfectly preserved the
whole time because it's plays a very
important function
yeah now because different mammals have
different versions of this it it would
it seems like it would have to make
sense that you have multiple viruses
that are doing this at once
so you know you're you're incorporating
some and one's ends up being better than
another one so the other one ends up
being dismissed through evolutionary
time the other one's magnified
there's like a conveyor belt thing
happening here it could well be and i
think there's some evidence in some
species that there has been there were
weaker ones at first and then then they
got replaced by better ones and in
particular the importance of these is
probably they allow much longer
gestation time
yeah and they're a lot longer gestation
time because it's they're making it
safer for the fetus to be attached to
the mother exactly they're not if the
mother goes out and eats the wrong kind
of you know nut or food or something
like that
has a little bit of boyar has has a
little bit of you know poison in it now
that that that can
avoid getting it it might not be enough
to damage the mother but might be enough
to do serious damage the fetus
yeah yeah
it can live it can basically and you
know when if you think back to what our
very distant ancestors were doing and
living
so you need to you need to protect the
fetus from
even things like viruses right it's a
lot harder for a virus to get through
that barrier viruses can do it but they
have to be specifically evolved to do it
to be able to infect this infectious
label cells and then get into the next
one a lot of the weird adaptations that
we find in mice are caused by ervs too
like there's a there's a color variant
uh that i've been looking at that has
there's a there's like a blonde color
variant versus a brown color variant and
the blonde color is caused by a
an erv which means you know that
infection depending on the environment
where that happened if it was a sandy
environment that infection could
actually be a benefit to the mouse it
could have it could have been
yeah um we we we actually discovered a
similar mutation in mice that causes it
to lose its hair
yeah
at a very early age it actually started
you know
it'll grow hair for a little while and
then all that hair will fall out and
never come back
and so we discovered that that was
caused by insertion of the nerve within
the
the gene that was not surprising
that mutation was discovered
in a um
an aviary in in london
uh by a night watchman who was a mouse
fence here
and this ramp saw it running it saw this
mouse with no hair running across the
floor and so we of course caught it and
brought it back and
brought it brought it home and bred it
with other mice to get a pure strain of
my spinal hair wow
that's funny
and uh
and that mice actually that strain of
mice
um was used very widely in australia
to test sunscreens
oh wow that makes sense
i'd like to be able to use my sunscreens
they're cheap and small and easy to
handle and so on
now it's a little hard with all that
here
do you think that most ervs spread
through retro retrotransposition so
there's an infection and then it spreads
no
you think they're mostly spread i don't
see that at all
or there are there are a few actually
not much in humans very i don't think
there are any active ones in humans but
there are a few in mice where that's
happened where they have sort of evolved
into into retro transposable
retrotransposons
i i think in humans i think what happens
is that
the
um
that you get um say a new virus comes
into the species
familiar we should be quite familiar
with that process right now right
and uh spreads it's like wildfire
in the case of a retrovirus what happens
is it sometimes
not all retroviruses hiv
probably does not infect the germline
very well there's the germline cells
don't have the right receptor and then
um
the infection is so virulent that they
might die very quickly so you know it
just never happens and things like that
so conditions have to be right
not all viruses not all retroviruses can
become herbs although if you look hard
enough usually you can find at least
some distant relatives like i mentioned
with hiv
but what happens the virus spreads far
and wide in the population
it may be causing considerable morbidity
and mortality people may be you know
getting sick and dying from it
and um
and and it infects the germline
and so
the
during that period of time when it's
when it's actively replicating in the
population and creating new germline
ones sooner or later dies out
it's always died out i mean
in in the human population
i'm sure there are population
subpopulations where it didn't die out
but then probably the population type
one it's one or the other by and large
and um at that point i think the process
stops
i i don't think there's any any any
reasonable mechanism in in the rare case
in rare cases like in mice you can
retain some that still have
are still infectious and humans
all of the infections ones that have
been weeded out
because there would be some selection
against them they would still if they
appeared they would they could still be
causing disease and and so on and in
mice and in mice as i said some some of
these do reappear and cause disease
during development of the animal they're
simply left behind as a static fossil
record
yeah
of the time when
um
when when these were active as a
epidemic epizootic virus
in our ancestral populations
right away they can actually be
beneficial
in preventing a reinfection from that
same virus okay so that's that's how you
that that that actually in my opinion is
the most important property they have
as far as what as far as good things
that they do
yeah
and and that is almost certainly
i think the reason that they go extinct
most of the time
oh so you think the the
the exogenous virus will go extinct
because there's everyone's got an
endogenous virus yeah that blocks that
is expressed in a way that blocks the
ability of the exogenous virus to infect
at least the infected critical tissue or
something now is that we know we know
there are a few examples of that and
this this actually is a phenomenon that
was discovered originally in chickens
and then in mice again back in the 70s i
think
that if they had the endogenous virus
they wouldn't get the exogenous virus
originally discovered because these
viruses were uh commercially important
in chickens yeah yeah they were caught
they were causing you know enough in
disease and commercial chicken flocks
that there was
considerable commercial motivation for
studying them and figuring them out and
one of the things that they found was a
gene in some chickens that were
protected against this infection
and so that gene became well studied and
after once once we had the tools to look
it turned out that it wasn't it was a
nerve
in which in which the envelope protein
was expressed so that that blocks the
receptor on the cell surface
and um but none of the rest was
expressed so it wasn't expressed as a
virus but it could express a censor so
there's a specific receptor protein
on every on a cell that a virus has
evolved to attach to exactly
and if that cell is already infected by
a virus that virus is going to be
producing envelope proteins that will go
out of the cell and actually stick to
that receptor so that the
other viruses can't get in it's not good
for the virus
to
push too many copies of itself into the
cell
yeah
that that that can kill the cell before
the cell has an opportunity to make more
virus
and will a virus stop its
self from reinfecting because i mean as
its genome is replicating yeah some do
hiv actually has a lot of mechanisms for
doing that but limit the amount of
replica you limit the ability of the
cell to be infected by another one once
it's already infected
okay it's saying i'm already here you
know it's like blocking the restroom
door
yeah yeah
so so so we only find when we look at an
hsl infected with hiv we only find one
or two actual insertions of the virus
because that's usually pretty small
you can set up experiments to get around
that for example if you throw in a lot
of virus at the same time they don't
have time to set up this barricade
okay
that is so interesting they're like nope
this is mine
it's
it's a it's a it's a war for territory
you know land ownership it's like yeah
well i mean you know
evil evolution is is not it's not a
matter of of um being better than other
animals it's a matter of being better
than your brother and sister
yeah yeah what the strongest harshest
competition is among yeah other members
of your own species because they're
trying to
exploit the same exact resources
and that that's really interesting it's
something you don't you don't really
think of when you think of a virus that
a virus is gonna
it's actually an enemy to the other
viruses because yeah it doesn't want
them on its turf
that's so that's so cool yeah so
the other
weird thing about these is that you've
got
you could have an endogenous retrovirus
that's been mutated to the point that it
can't produce a virus but you have
another endogenous retrovirus mutated
differently so together they act as a
full virus genome and they can produce
some weird mosaic monster of a virus
that that ends up coming out right you
do you remember xmrv
xmrv no oh really how people forget xmrv
was all the rage 10 years ago okay
xmrv stands for xenotropic
mlv mount miriam leukemia virus related
virus it's a horrible acronym it's an
acronym in backgrounds
and it was first discovered and thought
to be associated with a specific
prostate cancer okay there was you know
school thought that this virus was
causing prostate cancer a little bit
later on there was another association
made with chronic fatigue syndrome
you've probably heard of judy mike a bit
sexually
i no i have not remember pandemic
yes yeah that was that was judy michael
vince okay if you ever saw it it was
pretty awful anyway
she
was working on the possibility that
there was a virus association with
chronic fatigue syndrome which is you're
probably aware it's extremely mysterious
disease and condition that affects
quite a number of people
and yeah people suddenly suddenly have
no energy exactly it's quite
debilitating she began finding exactly
the same virus xmrv it was called that
because it's it's very much like but not
exactly like an endogenous virus of mice
dodgers mirroring the kidney virus
it looks like them you can kind of fit
it into the family of them very easily
if you look at the sequence and
structure but it wasn't there and she's
finding this and he was finding this in
human in humans and in samples and she
was finding evidence for infections
antibodies and things like that to make
a long story short you go back to the
front pages of science
magazine uh ten years ago there were
lots and lots of pieces about this it
was a huge it was a huge deal because
any time that something comes up like
this that looks like it might be
contaminating the blood supply for
example all of a sudden it's an enormous
deal because then then it means having
to turn over all of the blood banking
protocols and creating all assays and
you know it's a huge industry that has
to kind of turn on its heel to take care
of this issue
and um and and so it immediately creates
a huge amount of interest
not to mention the fact that it's
associated it was potentially a cause
and might
then lead to potential treatments for
a rather disease that was completely
mysterious
uh so and also it's got a very strong
very potent activist patient group a lot
of people nih particularly the group i
work with in maryland
um turned their attention to it partly
because uh the national cancers had a
fair amount of responsibility and that's
because the investigators were making
some of these claims had come from the
national cancer
cancer institute
i had the idea that this was this was in
fact an endogenous virus of mice
and that what happened was it would
occasionally kick over and infect humans
and that under circumstances
where there were a lot of mice as you
may know some viruses that infect mice
can become zoonotic and important
zoonotic infections in humans
under conditions where they're all of a
sudden lots of mice when you get a very
mild winter for example they don't die
off or you get a huge you know the oaks
oak trees have a huge harvest of acorns
or something like that the most house
populations will go crazy the mice will
be everywhere though and there'll be a
lot more mouse to human transmission of
whatever viruses have to be around it's
a well-known phenomenon yeah there's a
virus called hanavirus that you might
have seen that that comes up
yeah
exactly this way and there's been big
outbreaks of that in the west and i
think was an outbreak in baltimore some
years ago and is that an erv in mice too
oh that's that's not that's an exogenous
virus it's just circulating
well yeah i i my my idea was this could
have been the same thing
the same thing with endogenous bars
could be exactly the same thing if this
virus is also capable that the humans
were sar
or the endogenous most part not all but
some of them not those viruses
and so we started looking for endogenous
most viruses that might match
this virus very closely well we never
found one that matched exactly but we
found one where half of it was an exact
match
oh great
pieces of this were were exactly
matching
um but at the same time my colleague in
frederick was looking in a slightly
different way
and he found a virus
in mice
that exactly matched half of this virus
right we sat down together one day and
put the sequence of these two viruses
together they click together like a
jigsaw puzzle gave us exactly xmrv
oh my gosh wow
so and it came from two different
endogenous viruses and they take two
different herbs in the same mouse
okay so how did it get there well the
answer is that it's very common in
cancer it's not as common as it used to
be but but i think it's still done but
in cancer biology it's very difficult to
grow human cancer cells outside of it
outside of people
it is possible to grow them in certain
animals
yeah and there are mice a new called new
mice
um that that have the property
they have no hair but besides that um
they have basically no immune system
right but you can you can put foreign
tumors into it and they'll grow just
fine without being rejected but yep yep
immune system okay
well it turned out that there was a a
prostate cancer
that was passed that was transplanted
serially so you grow the throat from
you injected cancer cells into a mouse
it came from some guys yeah it was put
into the mice into one of these mice and
then the cancer grows and it's about to
kill the mouse you take it out and chop
it up and you put in another mouse
another must just keep passing deep
functionally
well along the way what happened was
both of these defective pro viruses
got together
and recombined into the virus that we
know is some rv they were both expressed
in the same cell in the mouse somewhere
right so that
between them they made all of the right
things they needed both neat both of
them were defective yeah we're missing
something but between them there wasn't
anything missing so they could make they
can make a full virus that goes on to
infect the human cancer cell
and that then
during the course of infection then you
get this recombination process that's
actually very common in retroviruses
and in this particular cases
recombination happened to we happened to
put these two pieces back together again
and i think it crossed over six times
and when you draw them
and uh and created this infectious virus
that went on and then infect the whole
tumor
yeah and then after that now the tumor
was being carried but now when you're
carrying the tumor you're also carrying
this virus with it was eventually taken
out from the cell culture
cell culture was passed around and
worked with a lot before we realized it
was actually making enormous it was
putting out enormous amounts of virus
but none of the people working with it
for a long time were virologists and
they had no idea was pouring out all
this virus which is effective for humans
fortunate fortunately it's harmless for
humans but it's infectious
okay so so people were getting this
virus
from
tumors they were working with in the lab
if they were just cross-contaminating
other cultures and yeah right the so
this these cells one thing that you do
is you store these just to store the
cells you put them into into vials and
put the vials into liquid nitrogen
and that because you have to freeze in
that coal liquid nitrogen is minus
100 or something like that and so you
have you have to you have to freeze them
down really cold or they want they won't
survive
so that's how you store cells
yeah store cells that are making virus
like that what happens not infrequently
these vials have little leaks in them
liquid nitrogen gets in and can actually
move the virus from one file to another
but you can have uninfected cells in the
same thing as this infected cell all of
a sudden your uninfected cells are
making virus
so
so okay let me try and piece this
together again so that's where this
virus came from it was purely
contamination from this virus that was
originally recombination
between these two different herbs that
infected
that were made by
by a mouse
okay so both of the herbs were made by
my it wasn't it wasn't a human herb and
no no there's no there's no human
component to it okay
and and that was contaminating samples
so then people thought that people had
this virus when in fact it was just the
samples that had the virus right exactly
okay
so we thought there was this huge
epidemic but it was only in the lab
it was only in cultures okay
wow
it's quite a story actually you should
read up on that you might yeah
that is amazing it is
it's scary too i mean we're yeah we are
lucky that that didn't that wasn't
something that could actually be uh be a
disease right
right well yeah i mean it's sad in a way
because actually
the hopes of the community had really
been raised very high by this
that that
for for several reasons one is one is
that
you know it's the kind of thing that
people don't even necessarily believe
they're sick
right having a virus associated having a
virus would validate that
oh with the fatigue syndrome yeah
so so we're still left with no clue what
causes chronic fatigue it might be 20
different things
that's part of the problem
the virus is very
very poorly the disease is very poorly
defined and there could be there could
be multiple causes caught it could be it
could be multiple different diseases
with different causes
when you're in that situation it's
extremely difficult to sort it out yeah
i've even heard people say it's
psychosomatic which to me is a cop out
for we don't know why
i have heard a physician say the whole
problem is they're not getting enough
sleep yeah yeah
yeah
so yeah i i know a guy who's struggling
with that right now
and he had to he had to quit his job
and
his strength will come back but it'll
come back for like two months at a time
so he'll go get a job again and then all
of a sudden he can't show up for work
and he ends up getting it's super
frustrating he just has this trail of
past you know while i was
working on this i'd go to meetings where
these people were and so on and it's
really yeah
it's really hard on them i mean there's
something or horrible going on but yeah
i i i really wish that this was right
for a long time well for a while but
when it became clear that it wasn't
that's
but
if you look if you look this up you'll
still find you'll still find blogs where
these people
claim that that this is still true
yeah and junior michaelmas claims that
it's still true and that's where she got
all
that's basically the start of all the
crazy ideas that you promised that you
have
gimmick
yeah i
it's been amazing learning how
how people come to conclusions i mean
covet has been more it's been just
eye-opening especially i don't know if
you know this but i did a video on
um
the potential natural origins of covid
before kovid blew up in the united
states
so i had
millions of views on this and i was
getting a front row seat to every idea
that people had about it you know the
thing that amazes me is the amount of
certainty that people have about it too
much certainty from the scientific
community too as as you know people who
early on were trying to completely
dismiss
this could ever possibly have come from
a lab
and i think that was that was over that
was there was too much certainty coming
from them there
and then you have the 5g people saying
this is caused by 5g towers
and so it becomes if you're outside of
the scientific community and you see you
see arguments within the scientific
community you see arguments with random
people on the internet
it gets really tricky how do you even
tell who to listen to
uh and i've just seen things spiral out
of control like i never thought you can
trace at least a corner of that back to
xmrv and judy michael yeah
yeah that's that's amazing
but it's you know in science we have to
live with uncertainty all the time of
course but people
people just don't understand that that's
the problem yeah
and and when you try and say that we're
uncertain about something it makes
people angry and they want to listen to
alex jones because alex jones is certain
and
it's
it's uh i don't i don't know how to deal
with that yeah it's an impossible war to
fight when i was looking in the
literature i'd hear all this stuff about
full-length ervs
versus and and this confused me i'm like
it's a full lengthy rv does that mean it
has every gene you've hit one of my pet
peeves yeah yeah
as we've already discussed at some
length retroviruses are characterized by
these long repeats of either end yeah
but what what those can do sometimes um
it's a it's a property of dna that where
you have similar sequences sometimes
you'll get
recombination between them you will get
the the copying system will start on one
jump to the other same one and you come
back and score so if that happens
between these long repeats what happens
is the virus the virus is all gone you
can draw this out actually really easily
and yeah convince yourself that i'm
right the virus is is basically looped
out and gone and what's left is just the
single ltr the single long-term repeat
right no longer a repeat of course yeah
it's one hand clapping but um
uh
it so that's a solo ltr and actually
among the herbs that we carry
ninety percent of them are actually
probably solo ltrs like this yeah okay
so for some reason and this actually
drives me crazy i have to say it and i
try i've tried to change it but i'm
unable to get any traction at all
some reason
the term uh
full length
came in to mean everything that's not of
solar ltr
so there can be huge deletions huge
chunks of the virus missing and it's
still called full length
i'm sure that bothered you a lot just in
readings and trying to figure this out
absolutely
anybody else is coming into this
literature from outside that hasn't you
know grown up with it is going to be
bothered by this and it really so i i
tried for quite a while i couldn't to
to
to to banish
uh the term full length replace it with
two ltr two ltr pro viruses yeah but now
making no assumptions about what's in
the middle between the two ltrs just
they're both there and there's probably
a little bit at least a little bit more
actually in the last video that i did
about ervs i wanted to talk about how
many how many are obviously viruses and
that we can they have all the genes in
them
um so there's no question because a lot
of people
you know
a big chunk of my audience is
wants to doubt this with every ounce of
their energy because um what it what it
implies for evolution i mean if ervs
really do come from viruses then
evolution is a thing and it can't be
denied and a lot of people want to deny
evolution so i'm trying to go and they
still watch your videos
oh yeah yeah yeah people people watch so
they can try and argue but i i try to be
to bend over backwards
in their favor um especially with with
something like ervs and so i only want
to really count it as a obviously coming
from a virus if a huge chunk of it is
there so the i can't remember what the
number is now i think it was 9 000
that i found
um looking through the database that
have both ltrs they have the genes on
the inside and they're but they're at
least 90 complete
um
so you know there's a lot of them but i
had to go i mean this
took i probably took three days just
going through the database trying to
figure out okay
if i want to be as skeptical as possible
you're better you're better than i am
i've never taken the trouble to do that
we work on a subgroup of these that is
about a hundred and that was those we've
catalogued very very carefully we know
what all products are and everything but
yeah yeah the ones you're working on are
they are complete because they're new
right they're complete in your
definition of complete because they're
new they're relatively you're only a
couple we've only found two so far
actually that if you look at them you
can't tell whether there's anything
wrong with them
okay yeah you can't tell us anything
there are no significant chunks missing
yeah um
that's what the herb k group right okay
yeah and and uh
and both of those as it turns out are
are also defective for reasons that are
more subtle
yeah they're just changing
misstatements in the code if you like
the 9000 i'm talking about they're
they're
they do have chunks that are missing but
they're not missing most of their genes
are still recognizable so you there's no
doubt that it's a virus right
i mean you recognize solo ltrs
yeah because they look
they look exactly like the ltrs and
viruses that have
they're full stuff so there's no
question about them yeah they probably
are solo ltrs kicking around
that come from viruses that we really
don't have a good model for that we
still still haven't really spotted yet
yeah
so so this when people say that it's
eight percent of the genome some say
it's five percent
um
they're counting in their really small
chunks
i would guess yeah i don't know i i i
never really
dug deeply into how that estimate was
made to be honest with you who keeps
track of naming things i mean who has
power to change how things are named oh
community is
actually there is an answer to that and
there's something called the
international committee for the taxonomy
of viruses i was the chair of the
retrovirus group of that stub sub group
of that for a while they take
charge of the naming of viruses and sort
of the defining of the relationships
what's what's a virus family and so on
and so forth okay but then there's a lot
of internal stuff how do you name virus
genes and so on and there is no
real consensus on that there that's that
that happens differently with different
viruses when you go to a meeting you
could be talking completely past someone
because you're using different words for
the same thing the retrovirus meaning
actually the non-aids retrovirus means
it does have a lot of aids in it it's
got a lot of other stuff is is that uh
cold spring harbor laboratory i don't
know if you're aware of that but they
they they run small sizes sign
400 people scientists scientific
meetings
a series about all kinds of type of
kinds of biological topics
they're on the north shore of long
island
and um
that that's the meeting where where um
where all the sort of the fundamental
electrobiologists going is
and that's often the place where um
where these kinds of nomenclature things
are hammered out
yeah
and uh in fact there is um
a self-appointed subgroup of senior
scientists there who
uh have have named themselves the
nomenclature police when somebody gets
something
and somebody gets gives a talk and gets
something wrong and no one takes a
police strike
are they able to maintain that within
journals too or is it just too hard well
the journals there are journalists do
say also set some certain standards
about that but
but
within
and there are much more strict standards
when you're talking about
um organisms animals and plants and
things like that about how you name
things
um
and but
in viruses
it's somewhat looser particularly when
you go from one virus group to another
because it's completely in a sense a
completely different community so the
way teams are named
that kind of thing is very different i i
find it so fascinating this problem in
science that i never imagined existed
which you know i work with scientists in
pretty much every field now
um
and there's just
an incredible difficulty with keeping
track of names of stuff
jargon in general yeah
i mean i ended up in
in this because i went to a meeting at
cold spring harbor
and um
this was the very early days of
oncogenes you know there
and everybody was calling their
authority basically the same thing
yeah all called sarc which was the
original one that was described in the
rest of homovirus
yeah and um and in fact one group
called the younger gene sark and had
another related gene that they they
called stark but they spelled it
differently
[Laughter]
with or without an a
and uh
i was sitting there and i saying this is
a tower of babel and so i just took out
the back of an invoice back in my
abstract book and scribbled a bunch of
names for all the genes that i was
hearing and
got together grab grabbed a a a bunch of
other sort of friends and we got
together and we
hammered it out and and sent in the
publication that became the standard for
all these gene names oh that's amazing
many of them actually made which
actually later on turned out to be very
important cancer even during the absence
of ours which is like james like grass
for example you probably heard of
whereas yeah yeah i named that oh wow
yeah i that
i think probably the the place that's
the biggest mess the field that i looked
at that's the biggest mess is
paleontology because you have um
not only do you have
just people discovering the same things
independently
you know different individuals of the
same species independently and then
publishing those independently you have
arguments about should we split this
into multiple species or just one
splitters and lumpers yep
you guys you got splitters and lumbers
and then you have people who just um
you know they made their career on the
discovery of something and it's
it's almost like
you can't you can't change it
that
everybody wants to respect the history
of the field as well and so like like
the names that you came up with if
someone finds a better way to name
something
there's going to be reluctance like ah
but you know we don't want to screw over
john coffin who named these and so
there's there's all these different
weird pressures going on
in the future
in that case of being very anonymous
nobody
nobody approaches me with that well now
[Laughter]
in your career what has been the biggest
surprise related to ervs one was the
sheer numbers of things that are in the
human genome
you know
that did surprise me and but we we we
knew they were going to be some because
some of the some had already been seen
by hybridization experiments and things
and and client clone and sequenced a few
them
but but that they were going to be that
many it was it was a very big surprise
to me yeah i mean to say that they make
up or chunks of them make up eight
percent of our genome that is insane i
mean that's a big chunk of weight it's
also hard for us to know
how much of these ervs and line elements
and so on
are actually
beneficial to us at this point because
you know we have found of course there
are ervs that have been completely
co-opted if you get rid of them you
cause major damage to the host right
yeah well and so i mentioned this in
sight for example yeah and embryos died
in early age
it's been done in mice it's been done in
some other species
and and we just don't even know how i
mean
if you were to take what seems like what
what used to be called junk dna i don't
know if you were if you've been involved
in those debates as to whether or not we
should call junk dna junk dna but
it seems like it's it's hard to tell
really because you could
using genetic engineering you could pull
chunks of dna out and see if it affects
the individual but
if it has a small effect on the
individual the small negative or
beneficial effect it's
it's hard to measure
yeah you've got to you've got to set up
an evolutionary experiment to measure
that kind of thing it's very it's very
hard it's doable and
fruit flies may be best or something
like that even in mice i think it's hard
to
it's hard to
do an experiment that would
really study the long-term evolutionary
cause of
changes like that yeah yeah is there any
uh
i guess maybe hope is the wrong word but
do you think that we're going to find
that there is still a virus around there
a herb k like virus that's actually
still infecting humans or do you think
that the evidence is in it
we've been trying to see if we could
find you know turn up evidence for that
and so far
we've turned up nothing so i
i'm not i'm not so sure that there is we
we're actually pursuing right now
a very specific curve k
that we suspect
might be
um protective might might be one of
these interfering viruses because it's
still making spike proteins and well
it's actually except it's not it's not
envelope um it's actually it would
actually be protecting in a different
way
okay which is known for some other
element not for i don't i think it's
known for some other endogenous richter
viruses actually they can interfere with
the virus once it's inside it can
interfere with other things it can
interfere with assembly if the virus is
made by by assembling exactly the same
piece over and over and over again
together
yeah that's how that's how the internal
structure of the virus is made you just
imagine puzzle pieces with a
tab and a hole basically yeah there's
the whole tab and the whole tab in the
hall all of a sudden you come to one
or it's got a tab with no hole
yeah yeah what happens that stopped the
process stops
yeah you can't go on
yeah and so you you could imagine that
just a small a single mutation in in the
in a protein that's that has to
self-assemble that way if it's expressed
uh could poison the whole process
that's what's happening in this case we
haven't we have some evidence in the lab
that it is
we have some other other we have some
evolutionary evidence that suggests that
it is
that's that's really clever have we ever
developed a drug that will do that
surely we have right um
let me think about that that seems like
an easy
there may i there must be some that will
interfere with that kind of
self-assembly i'm trying to think about
maybe not exactly that way but
yeah
there are certainly well-known mutations
and various kinds of things that do do
that to do work that way
right
and which which human populations have
extra ervs we did a survey some years
ago of all of the data from the thousand
genomes project that you probably know
about yeah yeah it's actually about 2500
or so you know
uh which is not very it's not very good
data unfortunately it was done with an
older technology and the
sequences were very short and a little
hard to put together so it's going to
get a little technical unfortunately
when the genomes from all of these
thousand genomes were kind of assembled
together they were they were done by
um using the known genome as a scaffold
yeah so you know where to put all the
pieces okay
if you came to a piece that actually had
was
had a new virus in it that hadn't been
in the that wasn't on your scaffold you
don't know where to put it
right
okay
or you your compute the computer program
you're using can't tell you where to put
it because you're you're doing it on the
assumption that the piece should match
almost perfectly not maybe not quite
perfectly but almost perfectly 90
perfectly well if it's half iris and
half half human uh then it won't match
90 percent it'll get thrown away yeah
fortunate fortunately they when they did
all these uh
when they put all these data together
um they toss all c all the sequences
like that into a
into a file we like to call the dumpster
file nice
and so we came back we came back at that
and did a lot of dumpster diving and
managed to find fine so find find the
rare rare hers that were her case
particularly uh that that were um that
had not been
that had not been spotted because for
this reason yeah and so we found a
number of them
we're hoping to find ones that were very
rare
uh on the principle that if they were
very rare and only relatively few people
then they're likely to be very recent
right if they're very recent maybe
they're representatives of ones that are
still in circulation
yeah and maybe they're also likely to be
much more likely to be active and
complete intact they won't have suffered
all the damage that comes with being in
the genome for a long time and we found
one that looked perfect but when we
tested it we took it into the lab and
tested it it's got a lot of mutation
it's got a number of mutations that you
can't see that cause it both of the new
ones we found weren't african
populations but it may be sampling bias
because there was a lot of
emphasis on african populations in the
generic
gathering of samples for the study okay
yeah that i guess that's where i got
this idea of populations because it was
oh it would be very interesting i agree
would be very interesting we just don't
have the data to address that yeah
yeah are there any any last things like
that the world must know this about
endogenous retroviruses before i sign
off
boy i can't think of anything right now
some people who are watching this might
be thinking about going into science do
you think that there will be careers
specifically in ervs in the future or do
you think there probably will i mean
it'll be it'll continue you know sorting
out
the
contributions that they have made
genetically to uh to us you know how
what they're do what what are they doing
that's important as compared to what
what isn't and what's what is
you know what what contributions have
they made to our evolution over the
years and what what functions are
important and so on and so forth
it's a very difficult question in
general very good yeah
they've basically just
broken the tip of iceberg on that dr
coffin i appreciate you taking the time
to do this this is fun well thank you
very much for the invitation